[Music]
is there a way to paint with a broad
brush
what people should broadly be doing when
it comes to eating i feel like it's just
chaos man so many people were confused
because a lot of influencers or people
trying to sell stuff whenever i hear a
claim my first thought is always
i wonder if that's bs
[Music]
what up what up this is john with the dr
john deloney show and we've got one of
the most important episodes ever on
today's show
so i'm going to skip all of the hootin
and hollering kelly had a bunch of
stories she wanted to tell james want to
show everybody a dance for skipping all
that stuff and going right
to it all right
so no big secret i've been talking about
my new book for ages now talking about
it talking about it talking about it
so i'm not gonna beat you up over it but
i have to talk about this if you were to
drill down besides mental health
diagnostics and relationship issues if
you were to get beneath that like about
help fix my marriage the next most
common question i get
is what should i eat why isn't this diet
working what's the best workout plan et
cetera so
in the new book own your past change
your future in my new book i talk about
in one of the chapters about
what's gone incredibly wrong when it
comes to our diet
with our food we are way off the rails
how we consume food uh the quality and
quantity of what we consume why we
consume what we consume what diet's the
best which diet's not all the stuff and
then i get into the scientific
manipulation of food the marketing
around food we have lost complete and
total control over this thing it's
bonkers
almost 50 percent
half
one out of two
all right these are my families these
are your families this may be you this
has been me
mo almost 50 of americans are overweight
enough to negatively impact their health
three out of four americans are
pre-diabetic are dealing with some sort
of metabolic syndrome three out of four
three out of four
and we are responsible for stewarding
our bodies well right
we i get that
but i don't think we understand how
deeply and how far the deck has been
stacked against us
it's important for us to know and i
don't say this lightly in drama i'm not
like some like
pinterest influencer that's like
not like that
we have to understand the war that's
been waged against our bodies
and against the diet infrastructure and
the food infrastructure whatever
this idea that food development
companies have hired psychologists
scientists chemists engineers marketing
execs to carefully design food to get us
to over consume and the goal is to keep
you eating and eating and spending and
spending and then it branches off
into don't eat meat don't eat vegetables
only eat fat eat tons of protein eat
cardboard and tree bark just think about
mushrooms those will fix every whatever
all of it
and i just want to eat i'm hungry i just
want to eat and i don't want to feel
guilty and i'm tired of feeling shame
and what's not helping is these extreme
reactions we've had in an attempt to fix
the problem
and you look at disordered eating which
is the most deadly mental health
diagnostic
and you look at whether you haven't
eaten birthday cake in 17 years or you
mainline pasta every day of your life
we've got to come to a better more
peaceful more enjoyable relationship
with food
we are in a snapshot in history it will
not always be this way and it has for
sure not always been this way we are in
a snapshot of history where food is so
over abundant
that we have an over consumption issue a
challenge of what to do and when to do
it
the story of how food interacts with our
lives and what it's done to our
psychology what has done to our
relationships is a it's a
chunk of of the book here about the
stories we've been told
and then we are left in the rubble to
try to make sense of it and we we wonder
we have mental health issues
relationship issues relationships with
each other relationships with our
science community relationship issues
with our food all of it
and so on today's show
i've got a guest
dr lane norton
i went and found who i think is
the number one if not the one of the top
few
nutritional experts on the planet and
here's why i think he's an expert here's
why i know he's an expert
he's a phd in the stuff
other experts when they want
um when they need data when they need
insight when they need opinions they
call dr norton
and
dr norton also coaches other people
he walks people through transformations
so he's not just an academic not just a
scientist of which he is a world
world-class scientist
when it comes to nutrition science
especially protein synthesis and leucine
all these other cool things
and he coaches people and
he does it himself he's also been a
world record holder in like squats and
dead lifts things like that he has been
a competitive bodybuilder and he's back
on the track to compete again this year
so when i look for experts i look for do
you know what you're talking about do
you have insight into the into the field
are you an expert when it comes to
content and
do you do this stuff in your own life
and have you walked alongside a bunch of
other people whether you're a clinician
whether you're a doctor where you're
whether you're a therapist whether
you're an athletic coach do you walk
alongside other people and put to
practice these theories these ideas this
data this research this science and dr
norton is all of these
i will tell you up front
to cancel the chance we get cancelled on
this one or i do he won't is strong to
quite strong because we're gonna get
into what's the best diet how do we
should we eat what's the best workouts
things like that we're going to get into
the hard stuff and i'll also tell you
this put your nerd hats on um i
mentioned this in the interview if you
want to know what it's like when a
couple of nerdy scientists go to dinner
there is some parts of this this
conversation that get real deep and they
get real uh technical
just listen and take in what you can
take in and move past which you can't
what you want to move past and if you
want to go deeper we're going to have a
couple of other shows down the road
where we talk about some of the depth
some of the science some of the reason
why we do this stuff and most
importantly we're gonna come back to
okay great i'm a single mom with two
kids just trying to figure it out what
am i supposed to eat i am an exhausted
dad i got a great wife we got two kids
i'm just trying what am i supposed to do
food prices are expensive this what am i
supposed to do we're gonna cover that
stuff here and in the future so hang
tight for my conversation with my good
friend and brilliant
and rabble-rousing scientist dr elaine
norton
dude i i can't even tell you i'm so
your time is so valuable i'm grateful
that you you join me here
easily far and away beyon
when it anything beneath mental health
questions like for depression anxiety
trauma the next most common question i
get
is what are you eating why are you
eating why do you say mental health
health and nutrition and mental health
and exercise all that stuff matters
and so here's what's been a
sobering thing for me the last few years
since i started the show
is i
value
being a good researcher and more
important i value being a good consumer
researcher research right
and i got sucked into this last decade
worth of
what i would call like the neo
dietitians
where this this new world of diets
plus
influencer internet charlatans
has created this cascade of y'all should
all be doing this and this and this and
this so for everybody
listening all of my chips are on the
table with dr norton and here's why
y'all everyone who listens to the show
knows i pay particular attention to
people who do two things at the same
time both who
are
consumers of research
always reading the latest stuff coming
out and they know how to do it whether
they're in academic circles still or
they know how to conduct studies they've
been a part of that and they work with
real people and are invested themselves
and normally what i find dr norton is
that people are either
they're they're like i was just nerds
they just read a lot and then they
extrapolate theories from mouse models
and whatever and then say this is what
everybody should be doing blanket
statement or they never consume research
and they just tell everybody what they
should be doing so
you are one of the few people that does
both you are one of the best at
someone who i look up to taking complex
science and speaking it into a way that
a a single mom with three kids just
trying to be a little bit better in her
day can actually interpret this and
understand it and then apply it in her
life right and so much
fellow nerd you and i could have dinner
for four hours and talk mechanistically
and talk about this and that and hormone
release
but 99.9 it's not helpful right it
doesn't it doesn't apply and it's fun
gymnastics but it's not it's not
applicable right so you're so good at
that
and i think one of the big problems we
have with nutrition stuff right now
is so many people were confused because
a lot of influencers or people trying to
sell stuff and to be fair i'm trying to
sell stuff
i am too so
but um
they they get people confused because
people don't know what to focus on right
so they they'll they'll cite studies
even though they might be you know in
vitro studies or mouse studies or
whatnot and people will give that the
same weight as people citing you know
large human randomized control trials
i'm like wait a minute no no these
things are not equal you know what i
mean like these things are not equal but
the average person doesn't have the
equipment to
kind of tease that apart and understand
and so i think a lot of people have
really gotten focused on the little
rocks
instead of the big rocks right like they
they're stepping over dollars to pick up
pennies unfortunately and what happened
man like this is chaos
like you can listen to somebody they'll
tell you if you're not a vegan you hate
earth you're gonna you're you're you're
just suicide just killing yourself just
slowly
um and you're a murderer and then you
got people like all you need to eat is
organ meats and rub you know fruit on
your face like and what what has
happened
what happened man
yeah you know i think there's always
been a little bit of that but i think
now you just you give
anybody access to the internet and
you know anybody can be proclaimed
themselves an expert and you don't need
you know there's a real like if you're
going to give medical advice you can get
in real trouble yeah you know what i
mean um
but if you're going to give nutrition
advice
nothing's going to happen for the most
part there that some of that is changing
but you know
i i think
for a year
dr norton for a year i put butter in my
coffee man i bought it i bought it dude
i did and i and even worse i proselytize
about it i told everybody who was like
having a piece of i was like oh i can't
believe you're eating that you know what
you should be doing you should be
mainlining saturated fats into your
like dude what happened man i'm a smart
guy and i fell for it
yeah and honestly a lot of smart people
so here's here's two things because a
lot there's a lot of physicians who are
making claims right now that are really
poor there are some good ones
um and there's a lot of like engineers
and all that kind of stuff
just because someone one is an
intelligent person
and two has a scientific background does
not
protect them from buying into bs like
there is
in fact a lot some of the people with
the most
horrible cognitive dissonance i've ever
met
were very very smart yeah and the reason
is they'll use their own
fact that they're intelligent to go well
i wouldn't fall for bs like i wouldn't
do this of course you would like you're
prone to your own not your own bs you
know whenever i hear a claim my first
thought is always hmm i wonder if that's
bs you know
like i start there and i i think that
if you're a good scientist skepticism is
something that you really embrace right
that is that's a good thing
uh because once you finally do accept
something that you you feel very
strongly about it it has passed so many
barriers to get there but i really think
a lot of the the confusion
again i heard a quote which i i really
believe to be true
if we're talking to somebody one-on-one
it becomes pretty obvious quickly who
has more knowledge on the subject matter
right like if you and i are talking and
we start talking about mental health
it's become it's going to become obvious
quickly that you have way more knowledge
than me on this subject
but if we're observing two people
debating
both who have more knowledge on a topic
than we do
we are horrible at determining who is
more knowledgeable of the two
because we don't like if it's not our
field we are not equipped to evaluate
the evidence so one of the things i tell
people if you're not going to become you
know a master's or a phd in nutrition
you've kind of got to find people to
trust and that's really hard because
some people
are just not trustworthy and you know
they don't have a sign on them that says
i'm not trustworthy um but it's really
kind of a dichotomy of what you should
look for
when you're trying to evaluate a real
expert so the first thing is they say
the magic words
i don't know yes sir that's it they they
say that frequently or they say they use
words like may
likely probably i was wrong possibly yes
yeah i was wrong i got this wrong they
they flip-flop right
um
you know because if you i always say if
you continue to defend a position in the
face of overwhelming data you're not a
scientist you're a politician yeah
that's what politicians do
[Music]
have you ever thought about how a lot of
us would drop anything to help somebody
else but we often don't give ourselves
the same level of care we spend time
energy money on everyone else but when
it comes to making time for vacation for
exercise for talking with a mentor for
sleep even going to therapy
we don't do it and we don't even realize
they won't even think about it
you are worth it
this month betterhelp online therapy
wants to remind you that you are
important
that you are worth being well and
therapy is a super important way you can
show up for yourself
better help is online therapy that
offers video phone even live chat
sessions with your therapist you don't
even have to see anyone on a camera if
you don't want to it's more affordable
than in-person therapy and you can be
matched with a therapist in under 48
hours today dr john deloney show
listeners get 10 off their first month
so decide to invest in yourself you are
worth it and go to betterhelp.com
deloney to get 10 off that's
betterhelp.com
dr norton i want to walk you through the
last decade of my life okay i even wrote
some of this down to make sure i get it
so
10 to 15 years ago i'm still exercising
like the high school want to be
like college wannabe athlete that i
thought i still was
every year i was getting a little bit
bigger and a little bit bigger a little
bit bigger and then atiya hits the scene
and
he's he's somebody i have high respect
for brilliant brilliant guy
his the first guy said maybe we need to
look at this differently mechanistically
then i got into gary tobbs and then then
i somehow landed to aspiri
and then everything was about
bulletproof and mainline stuff right and
so then i'm i'm i would cook bacon i
would eat it and then i would take the
bacon grease and dump it into my coffee
and i was a mainline it was it was it
was disgusting but here's what happened
i lost a lot of weight
and what i came to realize over time is
um
i would start eating at about four
o'clock in the afternoon
and what you talked about earlier was at
the beginning i was probably having
seven or eight thousand calories a day
by the time i'd been doing this for 90
days a i looked like emaciated and like
i had been left on a desert island for a
while but but
i was my
my caloric intake was so low right i was
i was eating that much but then i moved
over to you know baylor and the calorie
myth and then i got my own glucose
monitor and just started following all
these fad diets
man here's all the stuff my wife used to
say before we would uh
at the beginning of every month before
she go to grocery store she would just
be like john what are we this month are
we like raw vegan like what are we doing
she was such a trooper
um high fat vegan no carb no sugar i've
done it all all of them um low grain
all of it
every nothing is more of a third rail i
could mean you could sit here and talk
about religious rights and abortion
rights and we get less drama than when
you tell somebody don't drink diet coke
or you should drink diet coke right
so probably true
what are what what are we supposed to do
because i know how to read studies and
it's a pain in the butt and it takes a
long time and it's easier just to scroll
through instagram you know how to read
studies we do this for a living and it
still gets cumbersome
what is the average mom just the dad
who's just 32 and he's got two young
kids and he's starting to notice like
man it's hard for me to bend over now
is there a way to paint with a broad
brush
what people should broadly be doing when
it comes to eating and then we'll get an
exercise here in a minute
i feel like it's just chaos man yeah
so
there's actually a lot that you just
brought up there that's great to go over
so the first thing is
people make the wrong associations and
it's
just because something worked
it's important to understand why it
worked
right so we don't make the wrong
association so let's take intermittent
fasting for example which sounds like
something you did
um
people will lose weight and intermittent
fasting and they'll say something like
well see it's because it's because i was
in fat burning mode in autophagy and my
insulin was low
and it's like no dude you didn't eat for
20 hours and you fit it all into a
four-hour window and like yeah you lost
weight right but that's that is not sexy
that's not what sells people on it
because it just sounds like oh well
they're just saying i eat less i ate
less right and again it sounds a lot
like disordered eating right so right
yeah you just drive yourself
congratulations
and you you just brought up something
which is you slowly got heavier right
like you lose some weight regain it lose
some weight regain it but over time you
were getting heavier that's right
okay then the next question is all right
well maybe some diets are easier to
adhere to right compliance is the
science
and i really get into it like this is
it's like the messaging
behind what dave says with paying off
debt right yeah so people say well you
should pay off the low the highest
interest rate first that just makes
sense because of math
so well if we were doing math we
wouldn't be in this problem in the first
place
right
that's right because this isn't this
isn't an x is an o's problem psychology
it's not a knowledge issue this is this
is a habits and behaviors problem is
what it is
so
when we look at there was actually two
meta-analyses done looking at various
different popular diets and seeing
okay did any of them perform better in
terms of fat loss
also were any of them easier to adhere
to and the research showed that none of
them really stood out performing better
in fat loss
and none of them appeared easier to
adhere to because adherence appears to
be a very individual thing what's easy
for one person
may be very difficult for another and
vice versa and i think this is why we
have like again so much difficulty
because what will often happen and i'm
guilty of this
so i follow something called flexible
dieting which basically i have my
protein carbs and fats
the targets for the day and calories and
i just focus on hitting those and i i
try to use you know quote-unquote good
foods to hit those but for the most part
i'm just like let's just be consistent
with this right
let's make sure we're picking up the big
rocks
and
like i thought because
that felt easy to me because previously
i was trying to quote unquote eat clean
and here's what would happen i'd eat
clean all week this is in college i eat
clean all week my buddies would order
pizza on the week weekend and i would
eat like a whole large pizza right
and it's like hey do you do it's like a
budget right so
like if you are great saving throughout
the week but then you go you know you
know popping bottles at the club on the
weekend guess what happens to your
weekly budget it gets blown yeah right
right
budget still counts on the weekends and
guess what kitties calories still count
on the weekend
so i kind of was like well instead of
like going ham because i feel so
deprived what if i just allowed myself
to eat this stuff in moderation and just
you know just tracked it right
so i started doing that
and lo and behold it worked right in
fact i even did a joke i did an entire
contest prep
and i had
at least one ice cream sandwich a day
now i'm not saying you've got it it's
the greatest prep ever
well here's the thing though
because that stuff even though it's
tasty
you're getting pretty small
like intake for quite a bit of calories
yeah so i would by default as i'm
getting leaner and leaner my calories
are getting lower and lower
i'm going to have to adjust the foods
that i eat
to accommodate for that otherwise i'm
going to be really hungry so again a
budget example is great right so if you
make
a million bucks a year
right
if you
uh can pay your mortgage and you can
pay your utilities and all your
responsibilities and
um you set money aside for all the stuff
you need to and then you want to buy
yourself a real awesome sports car for
200 000
is that okay to do
maybe right if you can meet all those
other obligations right but should you
do that if
it's going to make you go broke if you
have a small budget right of course not
yeah right
um well this calorie is the same thing
if you're an athlete who's you know
expending four or five thousand calories
a day
hey if you want to have a slice of
cheesecake or something like that it's
not going to hurt you because like it's
just getting churned up in your daily
burn i remember that remember that photo
of michael phelps his diet yeah that
gave me so much i was like oh man i play
uh ymca basketball i can eat uh
seven big macs then you know i mean dude
it kick that killed me but you're right
he was burning up 25 000 calories a day
right so oh man um it changes
what you do based on that but really
what most people need to do is get
consistent
you just use two words that i hate
intentional and consistent
i need something better than that i need
a bad guy and
a special
intolerance and i need some genetic
information i need that the best diet
for you
is probably the one
that you can stick to
in the long term
and be adherent to and that is going to
be different from individual to
individual and probably the one that
feels
so in order to lose weight
you must practice some form of
restriction whether it's counting
calories low carb etc
but you can pick the form of restriction
that feels least restrictive to you
and that's probably what you should do
because it's going to feel the least
taxing over time
because consistency is the name of the
game and so just i want to interrupt
just just so the listener knows
in my house
i eat a generally low carb no sugar diet
unless i am mainlining ice cream and
gummy candies which happens um
but
my wife doesn't she has
many more carbs than i do uh and i'm not
talking i'm talking about grains and
sugars not not salads and things
and so it's as simple as when she makes
dinner she will
make part of the dish without the rice
in it or she'll make part of the dish
without the tortillas in it or whatever
and we've been doing that for a decade
now we've both landed on and i hear
houses divided that's just people not
being intentional not caring about each
other it's not hard um it takes an extra
three seconds to not put a tortilla on
something or to put but
it's a matter of what you just said
here's what works for us most of the
time and i can always look back when i
look and be like i just found 15 extra
pounds i didn't notice and i fluctuate a
lot i drop water pretty quick and put it
back on pretty quick
it always comes back to what you just
said consistency and intentionality
you all know there are lots of things
that make me nuts but one thing makes me
more nuts than anything else
buying a home and my friends who
refinance their homes they tell me it
makes them nuts too
i love living in a new home but i gotta
be honest
i'm no good at buying one and that's why
i'm so thankful for people like my
friends at churchill mortgage churchill
is a ramsey trusted provider who we've
been sending people to for over 20 years
to help with home mortgages why
because they're committed to doing
what's right for you and that means
walking you through paperwork that's way
over your head that means making sure
you get the right mortgage that you can
pay off as soon as possible and they'll
try to upsell you a bunch of nonsense
that's going to hurt you down the road
and most importantly when you're making
this big life change you can
actually breathe because you got an
expert in a team who have your back
listen if you're about to buy a home and
make a big change
save yourself the headache and call
churchill mortgage today at triple eight
loan 200. trust me that's triple eight
loan 200.
this is a paid advertisement in mls id
1591 in the mls consumer access dot org
equal housing lender 1749 mallory lane
sweet 100 brentwood tennessee 37027
programs are for select loan types only
and are not available in all states or
locations
what about working out what about
exercise um there's the
go run a marathon and if you've ever
been to a marathon you see people of all
body types and then there's the uh
don't ever run cardio again just lift
and then there's the
only do dead lifts and squats and bench
press what are we supposed to do man
i'm talking is the average character
just trying to get better at their life
now when it comes to exercise
if you're just looking to get healthier
you know because i my background is i
want to be the most muscular strong
human being i can possibly be and yeah
real
you were a bodybuilder so you did all
natural shows which is for the casual
listener that's like all oiled up uh
like pose down right
correct so i've done competitive
bodybuilding and then you hold world
records like in the squad and dead lift
so i've done power lifting as well so
power lifting is squat bench press and
deadlift and i was national champion in
2014 in 2015
uh qualified for the world championships
in finland in 2015. i got an overall
silver medal there
and i said it was
i set what was then the world squat
record which was uh and i was in the 93
kilogram class which is 205 pounds and i
squatted 668 pounds um
and so that's you know all drug free and
uh you know just belts and knee sleeves
that's right
that's incredible so that was um
so yeah i've got some so exercise is
different from you for you than it is
for sure for me for sure i want to look
at that on camera i want my wife to
still think i'm hot and
i want the guy down the street walking
his dog to think twice before he like
flexes up on like so what am i supposed
to do man
again
what you will be consistent with right
um the the now i will say i think
resistance training for anybody is about
the healthiest thing you can do because
you'll get cardiovascular benefits from
resistance training if you go hard
enough
um you'll get like it's literally the
best thing for bone density as well
um
you know obviously
if you want to change the way your body
work looks there is nothing more
powerful than resistance training and by
resistance uh dr norton is lifting
weights lifting weights yeah lifting
weights now let me do machines or or
compounds or whatnot listen i love
squatting and dead lifting bench press
i'm kind of okay at so not as not as
passionate about that but you know like
for me like
like today actually um i've been coming
back from some injuries so just before i
got on this podcast i spotted 500 for
five reps which is the first time i've
done that in a couple years i did 185
suckers how do you like that on my squat
workout this morning nope 195.
it's all relative
but uh like me like that's
that's like
that's like like i'm like i got my music
on and i'm like into it i like that when
i'm done i'm like man that's like that's
like the highlight of my week right
there you know yeah but not everybody's
like me so some people love crossfit uh
some people like olympic weightlifting
some people just want to do machines
because it's you know you don't have to
worry about as much stuff listen
whatever will get you in the gym
consistently
is what you should do because if you're
consistent with it
it's impossible not to make progress
over time as long as you are continuing
to apply
the principles that you were using
to get there so i mean again just like
debt right so some people are you know
100 000 in debt
and so they use these principles they
get out of debt well now what's the next
thing how do you progressively overload
that well now we're gonna start saving
an emergency fund right and then well
now we're gonna start putting some away
from retirement like you're
progressively
improving right so in terms of lifting
weights that's okay like
i've done this thing now i'm going to
add more weight to the bar or i'm going
to do more reps or i'm going to do more
sets right like those are all ways to
progressively overload so if you don't
want to plateau you have to continue to
progress but again whatever form of
exercise gets you in there and you find
fun and you can be consistent with
that's that's what you want to do in
fact for me
i'll have people tell me man you are so
dedicated like you have such good
willpower and i'm like
dude i love this like they take
willpower to keep me out of here you
know what i'm like don't don't think i'm
like some kind of like
amazing
um you know incredible human who just
slogs like listen i have days where i
don't want to go trained i do it anyway
but
for the most part
i love that yeah like that's that's the
highlight of my day right so
and there were seasons in my life when
when i was training them i loved being
in the mma gym and competing
i didn't like lifting weights and then
there was i know people who love to
run love to i love that i feel freeing
dr norton just to say dude just be
consistent
um
and do lift weights am i even seeing
some of the the long distance runners
now
circling back and incorporating
weightlifting as a cornerstone it used
to when i was running it was be as light
as possible
um only sprinters 400 and below need to
be lifting the weights and now
everybody's in on it just good for
everything weightlifting
whatever your sport is weightlifting as
long as you continue to do said sport
weightlifting will just make you better
at that sport i love that i mean they
told basketball players don't lift
weights because you know it's going to
mess up your jump shot whatever and i
remember uh back when i was in college i
remember one year kobe came out and he
was like 10 pounds heavier and he just
started like that was when he really
started taking over and then obviously
you see somebody like lebron james who
isn't like a power lifter but i mean
he's a big dude for an nba player
and there's a reason that like he for
you know a 15-year period most dominant
player in the game is because not just
not only did he have skills he
physically dominated people i know we
have very similar upper bodies me and
lebron uh like if i i wear big shirts on
purpose but if i didn't have my shirt on
our upper bodies are very very similar
um that's not true at all i just i'm i'm
lying to you
big secret
almost all of us can control our
thoughts
yes you can control your thoughts you
choose them most people believe thoughts
randomly happen and that we have to give
rent free space to bad thoughts and
scary thoughts and freaky thoughts this
is not true our world doesn't want you
to know this because they want the
privilege of owning your mind no more i
want to teach you how to take back your
thoughts
if you often find yourself lost in a
tornado of toxic thoughts and anxiety
and always on high alert you'll have to
be intentional about changing your
thoughts but it is 100
possible in my new book own your past
change your future we'll walk through a
not so complicated approach to mental
health and wellness that includes
learning how to reject harmful thoughts
and cultivate thoughts that move you
closer to who you want to be so go to
johndaloni.com to take the next step
towards wellness that's own your past
change your future at johndaloni.com
all right hey so as we wrap up um a
couple things number one
the
revolutionary nature here for the
listener
i this is not a this is someone i
consider the top um nutritional
scientists that i listen to period full
stop
and
when it comes to what should i do what
should it
intentionality write stuff down and
consistency keep showing up and keep
showing up keep showing up same with
exercise workout should i
just keep showing up and just keep
showing up and just keep showing up and
be intentional about it and write this
stuff down um along those lines um
you have created
industry insider the people in the
industry
say that you have created the number one
app for tracking this stuff and it's
called carbon c-a-r-b-o-n
uh by the way he's not on here pushing
this thing i asked him
you know what what's something can we
talk about this
i keep hearing it so great tell the
listener what's about this app
so carbon is actually it's called carbon
diox and android and it's actually not
just a tracker so
you know if you have a an app like for
example myfitnesspal i'm not dogging my
fitness pal because it's a great app
let's dodge them dude let's dog them
just kidding it's helped millions of
people
but
the difference is you know myfitnesspal
if you come in
and you say well i want to do x it'll
give you initial calculation and then
that's it and then you track right
our app is is literally a coach so what
it will do is you when you sign in
it's 10 bucks a month
and when you sign up you enter in some
different metrics so the app can get an
idea of where your starting place is
you tell what you know what goal you
want and by the way we don't it's not
just a weight loss app so we have like
for muscle gain
we have uh for maintenance we have
several different things
and um the app will use that information
to formulate your baseline plan based on
your own individual metabolism what it's
predicting and then your goal and then
every week
you log your weight and you can log it
daily and it will actually take the
average of those weights to use for
check-ins because actually as you know
john daly weights can fluctuate a lot
you may fluctuate a lot yeah yeah
i have to do
i have to take my weight every day over
seven days and average that to get any
sort of
am i going in the right direction or not
exactly i always compare it to looking
at the stock market right like if you if
you just go in an isolated day and look
at an individual stock like you might
flip out because it's down 20 right you
look at the overall arc of the stock
market over time that's right you know
it goes up right so you got to be if
you're executing on what you know works
like the app will work that's right but
we use we we recommend people weigh in
every day and there's a place to log
your weight every day
and
the app will use that when you do your
check-in which so you do that
every week
and based on how you're progressing
the app will modify your nutritional
recommendations to optimize your
response that's awesome
so it's not a static program that you
just download pdf pages off the internet
it actually works walks with you
correct and there's a great like the
tracker is very intuitive barcode
scanner all that kind of stuff
and um the great thing is like for
example like let's say you start a
weight loss diet and you know three
weeks in and you're actually losing
weight too quickly like the app maybe
estimated your calories a little bit too
low it'll raise them you know based on
what it predicts you should be doing to
hit your targeted rate of loss uh and
then the app can even prompt you with
different things and we're actually
working on making the coaching features
even more rich
um but yeah it like really acts as a
guide to take the guesswork out of
things i love it dude
it was yes so we just really we just
really tried to like
because we offer like we have a um
a team of coaches that do one-on-one
coaching or our team violin coaches yeah
um but you know obviously everybody
can't afford you know a few hundred
dollars a month just like like having a
financial advisor is great right but not
everybody can afford that that's right
that's right um
so for us like really uh we were trying
to see how can we like get something
that's affordable for almost anybody you
know at 10 bucks a month
and then you know make it user friendly
and so that's what we feel like we've
done well it's got a killer killer
reputation i'm looking forward to
checking it out myself cause i'm
absolutely i'm gonna get uh
i'm gonna get back in it dr norton it's
time for me to take that 185 and we're
gonna i'm totally messing like yeah well
and the other great thing is like we
don't we offer all kinds of different
dietary preferences right so when you
part of the process of going through is
like you get to pick what you prefer so
whether it's balanced which is what i do
in terms of your carbohydrates and fats
um plant-based
v sorry plant-based low-fat
low-carb ketogenic like we have all
those options and then even within those
options you can shimmy it a little bit
based on what your personal preferences
are to really because our big thing is
we really try to hone in on like how can
we maximize adherence
consistency consistency that's so great
well dude you're one of the busiest man
i know
you're a saint thank you so much
for talking english to those of us who
are just trying to get through the day
and get a little bit smarter and figure
some of this stuff out and you're right
it's like getting out of debt it's like
fixing your mental health none of this
is sexy it's just every day and every
day
and every day so i look forward to
hanging out in florida in a few weeks
and i'm grateful for what you're putting
out in the world we'll link to this in
the show note we'll link to your website
in the show note too
and um by the way your best protein
in the world that i use that's what i
use it's the best and you do sell
supplements but you sell a few of them
in their world world class so um and
i'll link to that in the show notes as
well dr norton i'm so grateful for your
time thank you so so so so much
everybody listening
be intentional
be consistent
and get
off a tick tock for god's sake unless
you're checking out some of dr norton's
takedown videos because they are epic
epic we have about the same size bicep
tube right by the way brother exactly
all right man we'll take care and we
will talk to you soon all right brother
thanks john appreciate the time all
right see you
all right so that was my conversation
with dr lane
norton
i told you you were gonna like it you
mean you can have diet coke yes if you
don't overdo it you mean you can have
i can have chips in case so if there's
an energy balance consistency and
intentionality so if you want to make
some significant changes this is for
real
not for everybody for most of us
get something to write write with get
something to write on and be consistent
about what you eat be consistent about
not pathologically not
insanely write down what you're what you
put in your body
write down how you feel
write down
what kind of exercise you're doing write
down how you feel be consistent be
intentional
and over time just like paying off debt
just like healing your marriage just
like being a better parent just like
being better in your mental health
healing trauma
little steps every day over time
there we go
there's no big bad guy here
[Music]
all right and as we wrap up today's show
kelly brought in these incredible lyrics
of the daft punk classic
harder better faster stronger
goes like this work it make it do it
makes us harder better faster stronger
more than hour hour never ever after
work is over and it repeats that about
11 000 times
take care of yourself we'll see you soon
coming up on the next episode okay well
i'm super nervous so hopefully i don't
screw up have you ever listened to this
show frequently yeah i'm not that good
either we're good same team i'm taking
custody of them in two weeks oh wow so
you filed for custody and you got it so
you're about to be a mom of a seven and
a four and a what three-year-old real
dang gina
wow you know i have a wife at home
that's missed me all day i have kids
that want to climb and then there's
other days where i feel completely
guilty and horrible because
i just want to sit and scroll so
somebody along the way told you
that the way you feel about things the
way you think about things doesn't
matter some days like i can't even stand
to be touched like my husband will come
home and give me a hug and i'm just like
i literally will cringe and pull away
and it's like just
what do i do
don't touch me